[Music]
good morning Hank it's Wednesday
December 26th and I'm back where it all
started in Asheville North Carolina at
mom and dad's house for the record Hank
almost everything I just told you isn't
true it's not morning it's afternoon
today is actually Christmas Day and by
the time this video goes online I won't
be in Asheville anymore
movie magic I can't believe I'm sitting
in the exact same place I was sitting
361 days ago I can't believe that was
361 days ago at any rate we've had a
wonderful time here with mom and dad
I'll tell you one thing about mom and
dad's house Hank you can't beat the view
mom's been in a particularly good mood
because I got a haircut although I do
find it a little weird that mom worries
so much about the cut and styling of my
hair now even though when she had the
chance to fully control the cut and
styling of my hair you have to say that
her judgment was questionable hey guy
don't know if you've been here since mom
and dad got the goats but man do they
love those goats we have been spending a
lot of time with goats over the last few
days now I will be the first to
acknowledge that mom and dad's goats are
absolutely adorable but I do have one
very small criticism of them which is
that they poop constantly I mean Hank
when you're looking at evolution and
you're trying to figure out why humans
became the dominant and most
intellectual of all species you have to
conclude that what held goats back
wasn't so much the lack of an opposable
thumb or the smallness of their brains
it was the fact that it's very difficult
to accomplish much when you have to poop
every 11 seconds okay enough of that I'm
not here to talk about poop egg I'm here
to talk about Christmas now Hank it's no
secret that I'm kind of a Grinch when it
comes to Christmas but when I got here
and I saw all the presents under the
tree in the beautiful tree and all the
ornaments and Hedwig I felt a little bit
of the Christmas spirit and yes Hank mom
and dad seriously have a Hedwig ornament
nerdfighter parents as Christmases go
Hank I have to say that this was one of
my favorites first there was the happy
dance project which has made me happy
pretty much every minute for the last
several days I mean I honestly think
that for the rest of my life when I'm
sad the Cure is always going to be
watching the happy dance project plus
even though I made a deal with most
everybody either to exchange used books
or just to give money to charity as a
gift I got some argyle socks Hank
there's a great line in a TS Eliot poem
light is the visible sign of invisible
light
well argyle socks are the visible sign
of the invisible nerdfighter now you and
I made a deal that we were
only going to exchange to use books so
you got me some awesome used books
including a history of Christmas and I
got you some manga when I asked you what
kind of manga you liked you said and I'm
quoting you directly here I like the
weird stuff so Hank I'd like to read you
the description of the manga I got you
sleazy alien moneylenders monsters on
the rampage and a ticking time bomb may
all be in a day's work for Jin but a
drop in his blood sugar level means
trouble for everyone I mean Hank its
manga about a diabetic samurai I hope
that counts as the weird stuff but I
have to say Hank my favorite Christmas
present probably the book I got from
wind fleet Hank don't be nervous about
tonight I'm sure you're gonna rock well
I mean to whatever extent a guy with an
acoustic guitar can rock Hank I'll see
you tomorrow two more quick things first
I'd just like to thank my dad again for
all of his help with editing the happy
dance project and second I'd like to
remind all nerdfighters in and around
Missoula Montana to go see Hanks show
information about that can be found in
the video info